mais dans l'intimité tu l'appelles Sting
ou Gordon
l'intimité je vais pas te dire
tu es là la femme l'épouse de Sting tu
as bien de la chance je suis sûr qu'il y
a beaucoup de filles ici qui t'ont envie
deux enfants avec lui mais avant de le
connaître tu dis que médianes et là
maintenant tu reprends ton ton métier de
comédienne tu as appris au holvers c'est
ça
ouais pas mal comme école et avec Peter
et tout sinon
[Musique]
je parle français comme une vache
espagnole
l'histoire que la femme Eva c'est moi
un casseret dans un loft avec un Mamba
cette serpenterie
et puis lui l'enferme à l'intérieur d'un
œuf donc juste une verrière au dessus il
peut pas la fille elle peut pas bouger
elle peut pas sortir de là et puis lui
il se met dehors et puis il a un système
pour contrôler tout ce que fait le
serpent et il peut voir ce qui se fait
qu'elle parce qu'il a un computer dans
sa voiture et dans sa collier il a mis
un petit micro
dans le dos de du serpent quand il peut
les voir tous et quand il les voit tous
ensemble ils savent
il l'a vu Sting le film
tu préfères Sting ou Gordon
Gordon qui est qui ne répond pas
il répond plus
[Musique]
l'intimité je vais pas te dire
alors on va faire une interview à peine
[Musique]
la chose que tu préfères dans la vie
l'amour l'amour
physique ou l'amour immatériel
ce que tu ne supportes pas
injustice l'injustice je suis une
Capricorne et je suis
janvier
alors maintenant le disque de Sting que
tu préfères de police
tu pars sur une idée
de police
si tu pars sur une île déserte lequel tu
emmènes
je pense que mon favori maintenant et
vous aidant
tout seul
parce que
il s'agit sur l'Argentine
je me demande pourquoi il a fait ça je
l'aime bien mais enfin franchement je me
demande pourquoi il a fait cette chanson
[Musique]
j'aime bien la petite toody candle quand
je peux la sortir et elle vient et elle
peut sourire et pense que que tout est
très amusant et drôle
c'est très difficile et quand j'ai le
jour comme ça je suis très très heureuse
que les autres est-ce que tu supportes
pas du tout en toi
[Musique]
j'ai quand je me fâche je suis une
personne horrible
je suis pas très belle quand même quand
on dit
quand je suis en colère je suis terrible
qu'est-ce qu'il fait dans ces cas là
et qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce que tu
préfères chez lui
parce que c'est un homme qui
j'adore sur surtout tout le monde mais
il est 7 norme le plus intelligent que
je jamais je connais c'est son
intelligence que tu préfères lui
c'est un des choses est-ce que tu aimes
le moins chez lui
astrologie il est un balance et le matin
il dit un chose une chose l'après-midi
c'est d'autre et pour moi qui est très
stricte
[Musique]
[Rires]
on est tous les deux tu peux le dire
est-ce que tu aimes le moi
je trouve pas
les journalistes qui existent il n'a pas
prendre potentiel écoute il a il est un
homme très très intelligent en plus il a
une visage très beau
tu n'es pas une fleur qui est comme ça
non il est très fier de ce qu'il fait
non je pense que le mot prétentieux est
un mot de journaliste qui sont vraiment
jaloux
tu l'aimes quoi
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu